yeah when you look at the details of it
he was driving buzzed not defend him you
cannot drive I think he just barely made
that limit yeah maybe had two drinks
decided to drive you know if you're
tipsy you know Tipsy driving is drunk
driving we've all seen those Billboards
right but there's a difference between
being hammered and driving a Tipsy and
driving shouldn't do either yeah uh so
there's no defending Izzy here all this
does is push the narrative that Izzy
didn't take Strickland serious I would
like to hear from Izzy Moore and he on
his YouTube channel he released you know
some stuff about the Strickland fight
but I'd like to hear more honest opinion
about this DUI I know a lot of guys at
the highest the high levels world
champions who would drink during Camp
not get hammered but have a few drinks
with red wine GSP red wine a beer hair
some whiskey a little tequila
you know what I'm saying so so some of
these guys can operate at a high level
and still get away with that stuff I
like characters he's like every Camp all
World title defenses even when I lost I
was drinking